you know one thing you should know about
espionage as well as bomb making
the first mistake is your last mistake
you're not going to live to make another
mistake
and therefore you have to be absolutely
careful you know one
wrong word you know and you are
a head shorter and six feet under
[Music]
of course i didn't wake up one day and
said to myself i'm going to be a spy
just as i didn't wake up one day four
years earlier
and told myself i'm going to become a
terrorist you know
you just slip into these things i think
unconsciously
it all started when i was 16
i was of course at the time residing in
my home country saudi arabia
[Music]
i was more or less a religious student
but uh of the rebellious nature
uh if you see what i mean so i um
decided and i have no idea what took
over me um
to go and fight in bosnia that was in
the year 1994 i was only 16.
the idea of going and fighting the war
in a foreign country that was seen
as defensive in the defense of
you know defenseless civilians i would
say that was
in itself honorable i think i wanted to
be part of history
uh part of making it and shaping it
rather than being a spectator
by the end of the conflict in bosnia one
of osama bin laden's senior associates
in the well-known mastermind of 9 11
muhammad he actually visited wasn't here
he was looking for talent among the uh
veterans of the jihad and bosnia to
recruit into the ranks of al-qaeda and
to bring them into afghanistan
for example you know he recruited many
of the future leaders of al-qaeda ramsey
benishib
two of the nine nine eleven hijackers he
told me that
uh for the next war for the next jihad
you need to be
better uh trained militarily the
training camps in afghanistan were
reopening again and it's better that you
go there for training and
so i did and is it here that you
meet osama bin laden yes i mean
my first meeting of osama bin laden is
not exactly you know the
first impression that people will have
when you mention the name osama bin
laden
the first time i met him was just when
he arrived
to afghanistan from sudan in summer of
1996.
he along with the rest of al-qaeda they
were escaping from sudan with their
lives
and they looked like refugees they
looked disheveled and
he was in a wearing creased robes and
his head scarf was you know in a bad
state and so
uh the first impression wasn't uh great
uh
in terms of the appearance but the way
he spoke i think
was quite powerful he was soft-spoken
uh that is something that everyone who
met him will agree on
that he wasn't someone who gave the
impression of being
power-hungry power crazy or someone who
would go on to commit atrocities you
would think basically that he is
you know a quiet uh shrewd businessman
um who you know certainly have goals and
ambitions
you know and he wants to fulfill um
that's how you would
he would come across to you and also he
would come across as sincere
not someone who is trying to sell you
something by deception
or by trying to employ underhanded
underhanded tactics no you really feel
that
he believe in that product that he is
selling you
he was very clear about his aims and his
goals and what he wanted to do what he
wanted to achieve
even though it sounded like the dreams
of a lunatic nonetheless
you know this lunatic would in five
years
time change uh the
course of history one thing i remember
about osama bin laden is that he
was able to read people i mean he would
look at me and he would think that
you are not a commandos type you know
young bespectacled you know nerdish
you know bookish boy from saudi arabia
you're not going to make it into the
you know elite urban warfare unit of
al-qaeda
however uh he thought of a better use
for me and he
sent me to al-qaeda's wmd
research and development unit and and
every day we wake up
you know from dawn all the way until
mid-afternoon that is where we are
learning
you know and sometimes either
experimenting in
blowing up new kind of explosives we are
trying to perfect or
unfortunately testing you know the
latest batch of
poisons or chemical weapons on poor
rabbits
at this point do you consider yourself a
terrorist
when we started talking
in details about the usage
of the weapons we were
constructing there these are bombs
or chemical you know gas devices
to be left on trains
inside cinemas nightclubs um these are
civilian targets
um and it this is why
we have the indoctrination lessons the
religious
ideological indoctrination in order to
tell us that there are no civilians as
far
as our enemies are concerned there are
no civilians
so we have to redefine what a civilian
is
to the point where we come to the
conclusion that if you pay taxes in the
west
and if you go and vote at the voting
booths
then you are electing your government
which
basically sanction the
bombings against muslim countries
and populations sanctioning the
siege against iraq on the killing of
many hundreds of thousands of young
children or so the propaganda was at
that time
so that is why we ended up
coming to the conclusion you know which
is a twisted conclusion i would say
that there are no civilians as far as
the west is concerned
what was the trigger for having you
realize that this has gone too far
i think the first time i realized that i
was
in the wrong place with the wrong people
at the wrong time in history
was um in early august of 1998.
i woke up to the news that
the american embassies in nairobi
in kenya and in darussalam in tanzania
were
raised to the ground by
vehicle bombs designed and driven
by al-qaeda members of our fellow
al-qaeda members
it was the first ever atrocity committed
by al qaeda
you know it was the first it was the
opening salvo of this war
they were telling us we were preparing
for against the americans
in the details were coming that in fact
it was
an embassy that 220
plus innocent
people from kenya from uganda and from
somalia were killed at that attack
because they were at the wrong place at
the wrong time 150 were blinded for life
the number of
uh the total number of people who were
wounded exceeded five thousand
the reason is because the device was so
big but
also they embedded thousands of
shrapnels
within the device to maximize
you know the number of casualties which
wasn't
excusable because the target is the
embassy when i destroy it why you want
to
harm every single one who is in the
vicinity what we are doing here is no
longer
um the acts of revolutionaries or
insurgents
it's you know it's it's it's morally
it's more or less pure terrorism
when i went to the de facto mufti of
al-qaeda at that time
and asked him the question whether you
know
how can we justify this i said to him i
remember that look i'm not doubting
anything but
i want to be at peace in my heart that
we did the right thing because
it's just 220 people dying
in order to get at 12 americans and
these 220 had nothing to do
with what america is doing in saudi
arabia
so his answer was quite chilling i mean
he said look we have
all this justification that if the enemy
is hiding
among civilians then we have the right
to go and kill them even if it means the
killing of these civilians and then god
will sort them out
i mean he went as far as you know saying
that you know after all there are a
bunch of africans who care
i made the conscious decision to leave
and i just waited for the right moment
to go i mean i already had
the perfect excuse i had a medical
condition that i needed to go and leave
afghanistan in order to get
to get it treated i left in december of
1998 just uh three and a half months
after the
atrocity and through some
um you know some incredible
circumstances i ended up
in the lap of the british intelligence
can you tell us how you returned by the
british
it so happened that i went to qatar
in order to just regroup and to think
where to go from there
and to decide what next to do
with my life that i now left al qaeda
i remember on the aircraft from peshawar
to doha
in qatar i was even recounting
and renouncing uh my oath of allegiance
al-qaeda i just wanted to go to be out
and i didn't want to continue with them
um when i went to qatar i ended up
actually being detained there
um however those who detain me in qatar
the authorities there were extremely
kind
and they were more or less understanding
of my circumstances
especially after i explained that
actually i was leaving
they told me that while they admire
my um idea that i wanted to
go to university uh you know basically
study history and become a teacher
in the future that while it is noble and
nice and
wonderful that you want to turn your
life around and there is a catch here
which is that
qatar is a very small country so
the reality is that you will end up you
know i will end up
meeting my former associates on daily
basis
you know in mosques or shopping centers
um and therefore the
objective of hiding away from them you
know
is more or less gone out of the window
altogether and so
they suggested that i should be more or
less
protected and utilized by
a much bigger agency in a bigger country
that will understand
you know the value of what i would be
able to do and then
take it from there and so that is why i
more or less found myself accepting
on the same day i had to say either yes
or no i said yes
on the same day i was on a british
airways flight
to london what was your
mission i think the question should be
what wasn't my mission
there were so many tasks you see
when you are a spy you know within an
organization like al-qaeda
in a place like afghanistan which was a
black hole by the way afghanistan was
literally the black hole of
telecommunications
in the entire globe at that time it was
even more disconnected than north korea
there were no landlines and there were
no mobile phones
the only way you can transmit
information to the outside world is by
going out
and therefore your task
is to absorb everything around you
so you are learning about the camps
locations the number of people attending
the names uh aliases
the uh the the breakdown
in terms of demographics you know
ethnicities of people coming in
nationalities people coming in
uh their ages where they come from uh
what are their aims
and then when you come out you spend
literally you know hundreds of hours
putting it back together from your mind
from your memory
and reconstructing it again for the
benefit of the intelligent services
were you nervous okay
i get asked this question so many times
where i nervous
you know one thing you should know about
espionage as well as bomb making
the first mistake is your last mistake
you're not going to live to make another
mistake
and therefore you have to be absolutely
careful you know one
wrong word you know and you are
a head shorter and six feet under you if
you are nervous it will show
it will show when you go there before
you reach there you really convince
yourself
that you are back to that old persona
that you are a genuine west hating
bloodthirsty jihadist and you have
no qualms whatsoever about killing all
of those
who stand in our way you bury your
nervousness so deep
in order to make sure that it doesn't
show
on my face i remember in 1999
in one of the camps i was in the kitchen
there were other people but then i
realized that
the people around me were leaving
towards the door behind my back
i didn't know why but then before i
wanted to
turn around and look around and see why
i distinctly felt the
end of a pistol against my spine
i distinctly heard the voice of one of
our fellow jihadists in the camp
menacingly uttering these words
now it's over give it up we know
who you are you know who you're working
for
it's over now you have to come with me
quietly
if he said the british or
mentioned specific uh you know
organization
you know i would be really
nervous possibly even you know i don't
know maybe faint
uh because i know what uh fate uh
you know will before me but because the
uh
accusations were so random i realized
that this is actually one of the tactics
they taught us about
which is to have random checks um so i
turned uh you know around told him
in no uncertain terms lower will weapon
it is forbidden explicitly forbidden
to point a gun at a fellow jihadist
and i want to write this joke so
the ferocity you know
with which i confronted him with more or
less
took him aback lowered his weapon and
asked you know for forgiveness that it
was you know
his duty you know and my name was on the
list
after he left you know uh
the kitchen even though it was november
in afghanistan
it was start to snow and no i was
sweating
in your buckets can you tell us about
anything that your intelligence that you
gathered
stopped one of the things about spying
against a big organization like al-qaeda
and being involved with multiple cells
is that
your information you know lead either
directly or indirectly
to the prevention of terrorism but in
some cases
the plot is so advanced that you know
you end up being part of it why because
you know i was an explosive expert being
an explosive expert within a guide
means that other cells will come and
seek your help and expertise
so this happened already in a plot in
order to attack
the subway system in new york in 2003
so i was more or less part of that
plot i was asked for help and i provided
the help but in exchange for that help i
was able to
um more or less understand the uh
the outline of the plot the participants
and uh
the direction where the plot was taking
place it was disrupted in the end
also there was a plot in 2005 not far
away
from where we are recording this in
canary wharf here as well as the city
and
mayfair to poison the car handles
of luxury car brands and the idea is
that
if you want to attack in the elite
of the bankers and the hedge fund
managers
um you know that would have been the
right thing to do
um this cell sought my help
in 2005 and
they were already obtaining the
materials to put the poisons together
that was disrupted the leader of the
cell
escaped britain before he was caught
and in later years he became
one of the senior bomb makers for isis
in iraq and syria
just to show how serious that plot was
obviously eventually you discovered you
were a spy
or arcade i agree with you given the
fact that i caused the death of at least
one or two
of their senior leaders in saudi arabia
and i have no regret about that
they resisted the rest um i would say
yes
they are angry enough to try to kill me
twice once in 2009 and one 2016.
it's a badge of honor as far as i'm
concerned all
all i did everything in my life even
when i went to bosnia was to protect
it wasn't my intention to go out to the
world and harm people
i jumped ship as soon uh as the first
atrocity
took place like either isis or any other
terror organization
you know are the true enemies betraying
them is
an act of honor not an act of dishonor
[Music]
and i'm like oh my god
and i start screaming off the top of my
lungs i started to feel like
something like just burning and eating
at my skin and just
i was hot i was sweaty it was just it
stunk